What happens if we predict the past?
Oh Shit.
Hello world.
It's Saroj and I get a ton of questions
about how to make predictions using time
series data.
So I'm going to explain eight different
time series prediction techniques to
predict the price of gold in this video.
In order of increasing complexity,
we can think of time series data as a
sequence of data points that measured the
same thing over an ordered period of time.
Another way of thinking about it is
that it's a series of numeric values,
each with its own timestamp defined by
a name and a set of labeled dimensions
and we're seeing this type of
dataset become more common. In fact,
if we look at developer usage patterns
in the past two years time series
databases have emerged as the fastest
growing category of databases.
Autonomous Trading Algorithms continuously
collect data on market fluctuations
over a period of time. It's like digital
wolf of Wall Street, smart homes,
monitored data points like the
temperature number of people in the house,
swag level and energy usage.
Jeff Bezos,
I mean Amazon monitors how it's many
assets are moving across the world with a
fine grained level of precision and
efficiency that makes same day delivery
possible. All of these applications
have one thing in common.
They rely on a form of data that
measures how things change over time.
Usually time series data sets
have three home analogies.
That data that does arrive
is recorded as a new entry.
It arrives in time order
and time is a primary axis.
These datasets are generally append only
the data that has been recorded doesn't
change since it was recorded at
some point in the past time series.
Data sets are different than just having
a time field as a column in a Dataset.
In that when we collect a new
data point for time series data,
we have to create a brand new row for it.
We can't overwrite what happened before.
Only by doing this will we
be able to track all changes
to assist them over time.
Recording data points over a series of
time allows us to analyze how something
has changed in the past.
Monitor how is changing in the presence
and even predict how it could change in
the future.
So let's say we have a Dataset of the
price of gold over a period of time from
many days ago up until today,
we want to be able to predict the price
of gold tomorrow using this datasets.
How are we going to do that dark
magic? Well, before we do anything,
let's split our data into
training and testing data.
We can use the popular machine learning
library called psychic learn and pandas
to do this. Let's start with
the most naive approach we can.
If we want to forecast
the price for a given day,
we can just take the last days value of
our training set and use it to estimate
the same value for the next day. We can
represent this as the equation y hat.
The price of gold of the next day is
equal to y the price of gold from the
previous day.
That's the most basic time series
forecasting equation we could make.
Then we can check the accuracy of
our model on the testing data set.
By using psychic learns
mean squared error module.
It'll allow us to compute the
error between our prediction
and the testing data
set, which are the real values for
all the data points we predict.
We can compute the root mean squared
error and it will output a scalar value.
As you can see, this value is pretty
bad. We could do much better, so instead,
let's try using a different
method called the simple average.
Sometimes we get a Dataset that varies
by a small margin through its time
period, but the average at each
time period remains constant.
We can thus try and forecast the price
of the next day using the average of all
the past days.
The expected value will then be equal to
the average of all previously observed
data points. It's not going to be exact,
but it can be somewhat close, right?
Actually,
when we compute the error again,
we'll see that this model
didn't improve our score.
This method works best when the average
at each time period is constant,
but even though the naive methods
scored better than the average method,
it doesn't mean the naive
method is universally better.
It just happened to be better.
In this case.
If in our graph we can see that there's
a big difference in terms of the prices
in the initial period
and the later period.
Perhaps we could improve
our simple average approach
by only taking the average
of the prices for the last time period
only we'd call this the moving average.
We just need to pick the right value for
p where p is the fixed finite number of
previous values.
When we test this out,
we can see that we are
getting better at predictions,
are error is smaller and our prediction
line intersects much more of our test
data.
One thing we could possibly do to improve
our model is add some weights to our
values. Meaning it seems like
the more recent the data points,
the more it matters.
If we gave different weights within
the sliding window of values,
which all add up to one,
we can mathematically define a preference
for values that came later on in the
series.
Notice that both the simple average
and the weighted moving average are on
opposite ends of the spectrum in terms of
how they approach the problem. Ideally,
we can use a method that incorporates
ideas from both techniques combining them
like a megazord.
It's clear that attaching larger weights
to more recent observations and two
observations from the
distant past will work well,
but instead of manually
deciding what those weights are,
let's define a smoothing
parameter called Alpha.
The rate at which the weights
will decrease is controlled
by this parameter and
we can make the equation more simple and
that the of y hat just turns out to be
the sum of just two products.
We've created a weighted moving average
with two weights because the expression
is recursive. This is an
exponential method. Simple,
exponential smoothing to be exact,
but still it's not taking into account
just how much variation there is in our
data.
Charles Holt,
a professor at Carnegie Mellon noticed
this problem a few decades ago and
extended the idea of simple,
exponential smoothing to allow for
forecasting of data with a trend.
This method called Holts.
Linear trend applies exponential
smoothing to both the level and the trend.
The trend is the general pattern of
prices that we observe over a time period
and the level is the average
value in this series.
To Express this mathematically, we
need three equations, one for level,
one for trend and one to combine
both to get the expected forecast.
The level equation demonstrates that
it's the weighted average of the
observation and the within
sample one step ahead forecast.
While the trend equation shows that
it's a weighted average of the estimated
trend at time t based on the other values
as well as the previous estimate of
the trend,
this model is better but it's still not
taking the variation into account as
well as we'd like.
So let's look at one more improvement
from our buddy Holt hold notice that
sometimes there are trends that depend
on certain seasons. For example,
a store that sells winter clothing will
usually make more sales in the winter
instead of this summer and this is a
pattern that repeats as the seasons change
yearly,
we can call this pattern seasonality
and data sets that show a similar set of
patterns after fixed intervals
over a time period. Exhibit.
This Holtz winter method takes into
account both trend and seasonality to
forecast prices.
We apply exponential smoothing to the
seasonal components in addition to level
and trend, each has its own
unique smoothing parameter.
The level equation we'll show the
weighted average between the seasonally
adjusted observations and the non
seasonal forecast from time t.
The trend is the same as holds linear
method and the seasonal equation shows a
weighted average between the current
seasonal index and the seasonal index of
the same season. Previously,
when we plot this,
we get our lowest error yet and our
prediction finally looks like it's fitting
or testing data,
but wait before you try and
collapse the financial markets.
As great as that last method was,
keep in mind that so far we've only
looked at univariate time series data
meeting. It's a series. What they
single time dependent variable.
Usually though in the real world there
are multiple variables at play and
handling all of them at the same
time is a skill that can be mastered.
This is instead considered
multi-variate time series data.
Each variable in a multivariate time
series depends not only on its past values
but also has some dependency
on other variables.
Want to use these dependencies
to help forecast future values.
One of the most commonly used methods
for multivariate time series forecasting
is called vector auto regression
or or bar and the bar model.
Each variable is a linear function of
the past values of itself and the past
values of all other variables.
If we have two variables,
y one and y two and we need to forecast
the value of these two variables at a
given time, we can represent the
relation between both. As such,
we've got constant terms,
coefficients and error terms here in order
to use the multiple variable terms in
each equation we'll use vectors,
but what else could we do here?
Well,
we haven't yet used a learning technique.
Recurrent neural networks are able to
learn how to make predictions in sequences
of data and a variance of recurrent
networks called long short term memory
networks are able to learn from
even longer sequences of data.
We can treat our Dataset as a supervised
problem if we'd like and use an LSTM
network to predict our target.
We could also use reinforcement learning
where we frame the market as a Markov
decision process and use real time reward
signals from the market to help adjust
our predictions as in if our buy and
sell decisions affect the price of gold,
I've got videos on both of those topics.
Link will be in the video description.
There are three things to remember from
this video for univariate time series.
Data Holtz winter method works pretty
well for multivariate at time series data.
We can use a model called
[inaudible] auto regression,
and if we're feeling ambitious,
we can use a learning technique like
recurrent networks to help learn trends in
the data rather than using a static model.
I'm so proud of you for
making it to the end.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos, and for now,
I'm going to go forward in time,
so thanks for watching.